firstly before proceeding with the video
ensure that you are in a space where you
are free from distractions and can fully
submit to this visualization exercise
during the exercise
let yourself immerse into the reality
that is being described let your
imagination take control and allow for
the emotions and sensations it creates
if you would like you may close your
eyes but it is not necessary now
visualize yourself in the following
circumstance it is the morning and you
have just woken up you are not sure what
time it is or what day you are in a
starkly Licht
hospital room the smell is pungently
sterile and there is an inescapable
bitter taste in your mouth you have been
here for weeks maybe months you can't
really remember through no fault of your
own you have been in an accident that
has caused severe brain damage and
rendered you paralyzed you cannot move
your arms legs torso nothing you can
open your mouth but you cannot form
words just garbled throat sounds you can
see and hear everything around you and
you can understand what is happening but
you cannot engage in any of it you
cannot get up and move through it you
can do nothing but lie lifelessly on
this hospital bed staring at the ceiling
a nurse comes in once in a while on
their rounds to check up on you this
stranger cleans you and changes you if
you have any requests or need anything
they cannot understand you they try to
guess what you want or need they're
almost always wrong
if you're lucky they'll put on the TV
but it is never what you want to watch
now and again some family and friends
stopped in to visit you their visits
have become less and less frequent when
they do come they talk to you like you
don't understand they talk to you like a
child and often they don't talk to you
at all
instead they talk to each other about
you as if you aren't there you want so
desperately to reach out and hug them
you need so badly to let them know how
you feel to answer their questions and
to prove that you can still be loved
without it feeling like a charity but
you can't this is it for the rest of
your life you are this you are helpless
and hopeless for anything beyond a
vegetative state you can't even kill
yourself if you wanted to if you're
lucky maybe you all get to go home soon
and lay in your own bed only to stare at
a different ceiling every dream you ever
had for the future gone any activity you
wanted to enjoy this weekend impossible
everything you once knew any skill you
once had any success you once work for
essentially meaningless your life is
over with so many years left to live
now stop if they are closed open your
eyes step away from this reality let it
dissolve as you return to your own life
look at the world around you and recall
the conditions of your life recognize
the functioning body and mind that you
have acknowledged the words that you can
speak the people you can have healthy
relationships
the places you can go and the things you
can do all on your own free will
acknowledge all the little or boring
things that you might take for granted
every day your life may seem challenging
or dark at times and perhaps it is but
happiness is malleable it is influenced
by perception and perception is
influenced by how you choose to see and
think about things and this exercise
helps remind us how to think about
things it reminds us of what we have and
what we could lose at any moment if you
ever start to feel sorry for yourself
or lost in darkness try to remember the
feelings you just experienced try to
remember and you still have a lot to
appreciate and happiness only comes when
you appreciate it
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and wonder